did you guys get a chance to have any
fun and explore a little bit the group
of us out there none of us really knew
each other and then sort of they in that
intense sort of environment for three
months and we're trying together with a
horse shod together with you know
obviously onset all that together and
you form is great to the friendship and
a lot of our sort of you know the
relationships from each of us I think
then sort of back out onto the page and
it was other sort of chemistry that
wasn't in the script that came about
just through our interactions and Bulls
drive once we land we're about nine
hours away from help effectively means
it doesn't exist we're on our own
we all need to understand the capture is
not an option here
you tell a story that's this important
do you feel pressure in playing this
case I mean do a few members I mean
there were actually there top to only
there was a couple of guys you know the
tool command we're there and you do feel
this sense of responsibility to make
sure that you you tell the story as best
you can what about the depiction of some
of the warlords and the Taliban and that
portrayal what I was really proud of and
I number of people on set a few Afghan
soldiers who were in Afghanistan when
this is happening we're so proud of this
movie because it was highlighting the
relationship between the local Afghan
people and the American soldiers and
then fighting together the common enemy
being a Taliban and al-qaeda and they
said it was sort of doing away with some
of the misconception of sort of that
everyone from Afghanistan or from that
area was the enemy and and I was so
happy that this story was being told and
so that might I think a lot of us feel
pretty proud to be a part of and Mike
that no did you see the thing Ryan did
with who's the hottest Chris did you see
that I keep getting asked who I think
he's hotter Ryan Reynolds got asked who
the hottest Chris was no ROI and there
was three different Chris's so he's like
who do you think the hottest Chris is
because there's a lot of attractive
Kristin's this price you to pick one yes
Chris do you think Chris Pratt's the
most attractive I love Chris Pratt you
love him I love Chris Evans did you guys
debate on who the hottest Ryan that's
actually like before I even came out
that was a constant
and the number one always was different
you're like yeah probably golfing right
okay
and in Ryan Seacrest cigarettes I mean
how do you choose go that's just math I
guess I'll just go for the other dogs
eat grass
yeah it's got gun secrets yes yeah